the government's education a covid
recovery program is in turmoil tonight
following the shock offer to resign by
sir kevin collins
the person appointed by the prime
minister to draw up plans for extra
tuition
and uh tutoring extra lessons uh
children being allowed to stay on for an
extra
uh an extra year and so on to catch up
from the lessons lost during the
pandemic this is a letter reported by
the times education supplements
that kevin has sent to the prime
minister this evening
it says i am writing to offer my
resignation as
education recovery commissioner and he
goes on to talk about the disruption in
education
caused by the pandemic and then he says
this
when we met last week i told you i do
not believe it will be possible to
deliver
a successful recovery without
significantly
greater support than the government has
to date
indicated it intends to provide and
that's those uh disputed figures the 1.4
billion pounds
gavin williamson pledged today and the
reports that uh
sir kevin wanted up to 15 billion
probably more like 13
we understand he goes on i am concerned
that the apparent
savings offered by an incremental
approach to recovery
represent a false economy as learning
losses that are not addressed quickly
are likely to compound and uh he uh
concludes
um as i've set out in my reports to you
i do not believe that it is uh credible
that a successful recovery can be
achieved with a program
of support of this size so
this is a row about money uh earlier in
the week it was reported that uh sir
kevin's
was proposing proposals for a longer
school day
eight in the morning to five or six pm
at night would be in the package of
measures announced by mr williamson
they were not because of cost a row
between mr williamson and
rishi sunak the chancellor over funding
and
now it's clear that uh sir kevin the man
who draw up the proposals
uh is threatening to walk we do not know
yet
for with any certainty from number 10
whether the prime minister has accepted
his resignation
but this is an embarrassing blow and of
course
a lot of the critics of the government's
funding proposals 1.4
billion pounds teaching unions
opposition mps
other education campaigners will say
told you so
this is not enough um today the prime
minister said
that the uh proposals that were uh
as he called it the biggest tutoring
program anywhere in the world well
critics have said that is not the case
and it is dwarfed in comparison with
what some other countries are doing
but the whole program now is in turmoil
because the man who was
who drew up the proposals and was due to
carry on
uh with a review of whether the school
day should be extended
uh by half an hour or whatever to help
children catch up
he's quitting and so the government the
whole program
now is in disarray and some
embarrassment
for the prime minister